[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic les mathématiques de la relativité
générale sortie 8 résumé et applications
[Musique]
pour conclure cette série de vidéos nous
allons résumé tous les concepts
développés en proposant un catalogue des
différentes solutions possibles et en
les mettant en application dans
plusieurs exemples concrets on pourra
calculer la dilatation du temps que
subit un astronaute dans la station
spatiale
déterminés les équations qui régissent
le mouvement d'un objet tombant sur le
soleil et même la trajectoire de la
lumière autour d'un trou noir pour
commencer résumons ensemble les
différentes étapes qui permettent de
résoudre un problème en relativité
générale
la première étape est de déterminer la
géométrie d'espace-temps dans laquelle
on veut résoudre notre problème
ceci correspond à trouver la métrique
que l'on va utiliser dans un univers
vide on utilisera la métrique de
minkowski qui décrit l'espace-temps plat
de la relativité restreinte autour d'une
masse sphérique et statique on utilisera
la métrique de schwarzschild c'est la
métrique la plus utilisée en relativité
générale car elle est simple mais peut
tout de même s'appliquer un grand nombre
de situations autour d'une planète d'une
étoile ou même autour d'un trou noir
statique
il existe également un panel d'autres
métriques plus exotiques comme la
métrique flr w qui décrit l'univers tout
entier à grande échelle la métrique de
maurice thorn qui décrit un trou de ver
non attractif ou encore la métrique de
care qui décrit un trou noir tournant
rapidement sur lui-même la seconde étape
est de choisir les coordonnées que l'on
va utiliser pour décrire notre problème
en fonction de notre situation
certaines coordonnées sont plus
appropriés que d'autres en particulier
la métrique de minkowski s'exprime la
plupart du temps avec des coordonnées
cartésienne qui reflète bien son
invariance dans l'espace et dans le
temps et la métrique de schwarzschild
avec des coordonnées à symétrie
sphérique tout comme l'astre que l'on
étudie cela dit notre problème peut ne
corresponde à aucune de ces solutions
habituelles et il va falloir dans ce cas
déterminé par nous mêmes les coordonnées
les plus appropriées et partir
directement de l'équation d'einstein
pour intégrer les différents temps soeur
de courbure est remonté jusqu'à
l'expression du tenseur métriques
ce procédé peut s'avérer extrêmement
complexe et nécessite la plupart du
temps des approximations et des
simulations informatiques
une fois nos coordonnées choisi la
troisième étape consiste à analyser les
symétries de notre problème pour réduire
son nombre de dimensions
par exemple pour décrire le mouvement
d'une pomme tombant verticalement n'aura
besoin que d'une seule dimension des
espaces on peut décrire sa position le
long d'un seul axe de même pour un objet
en orbite autour d'une masse sphérique
la symétrie nous indique que sa
trajectoire est confiné dans un plan par
symétrie l'objet n'a aucune raison de
sortir de ce plan d'un côté plutôt que
de l'autre dans ce cas on peut se
ramener à deux dimensions des espaces en
alignant nos coordonnées avec ce plan
enfin une fois notre métriques et nos
coordonnées déterminé on va pouvoir
exprimer la solution de notre problème
deux possibilités s'offrent alors à nous
dans un premier temps on peut vouloir
exprimer les composantes de la vitesse
de notre objet dans l'espace temps par
exemple on peut vouloir exprimer sa
vitesse temporel c'est à dire le rythme
auquel s'écoule notre temps par rapport
à son temps propre
dans ce cas on utilisera le fait que
tous les objets de l'univers se déplace
à la vitesse de la lumière
la norme de sa vitesse doit donc être
égal à la vitesse de la lumière
ce qui nous donne une équation qui relie
entre elles les composantes de la
vitesse dans un second temps une fois
que l'on connaît les différentes
composantes de la vitesse de notre objet
on peut s'intéresser à leurs
accélérations
c'est à dire la façon dont elles évolué
au cours du temps propre
on pourra ainsi décrire des trajectoires
complète à travers l'espace temps par
exemple on peut vouloir calculé le
mouvement d'une pomme qui tombe sur
terre où la trajectoire de la terre
autour du soleil
dans ce cas il est nécessaire de
calculer les symboles de christophe
elles pour pouvoir les injecter dans
l'équation des géodésique dans le cas de
la pomme par exemple cette équation nous
dit que ça coordonnées d'altitude va
subir une accélération négative
elle tombe pour résumer on commence par
choisir une géométrie d'espace-temps
pour décrire notre univers puis ont
réduit le nombre de dimensions a étudié
à partir des symétries de notre problème
et enfin on utilise dans un premier
temps la norme de la vitesse pour relier
ses différentes composantes et dans un
second temps
l'équation des géodésique pour calculer
la trajectoire complète de l'objet grâce
à cette méthode
nous allons pouvoir résoudre étape par
étape un grand nombre de problèmes
physiques
exemple un la dilatation du temps dans
ce premier exemple on souhaite
déterminer la dilatation du temps que
subit un astronaute dans la station
spatiale pour résoudre ce problème nous
allons suivre les différentes étapes que
l'on a énoncé précédemment
tout d'abord on choisit la métrique qui
décrit le mieux notre situation on
considèrera que la terre est une sphère
parfaite et on négligera sa rotation sur
elle-même qui est très faible devant la
vitesse de la lumière dans ce cadre
simplifiée l'espace temps à l'extérieur
de la planète est décrit par la métrique
de schwarzschild sous sa forme la plus
intuitive la métrique de chart's shield
s'exprime avec des coordonnées sphérique
mesure est depuis l'infini on imagine
qu'on se place à très grande distance de
la planète et qu'on mesure le temps tu
es sur notre horloge l'altitude air de
la station depuis le centre de la terre
et les ongles et à efi le temps soeur
métriques prend alors la forme suivante
une fois le temps soeur métriques
exprimé dans les quatre dimensions de
l'espace temps on va tenter de le
réduire en exploitant les symétries du
problème en particulier
on suppose que la station décrit un
cercle autour de la terre en s'alignant
sur ce cercle
on peut s'affranchir d'une part de
l'accord donne et état car la station
orbite dans un plan et d'autre part de
l'altitude air qui reste constante tout
au long de la trajectoire
ainsi on peut supprimer les lignes et
colonnes qui correspondent à ces deux
corps donné la position de l'astronaute
dans l'espace temps peut être décrite
avec seulement deux dimensions le tenter
et l'angle fille enfin une fois le temps
soeur métriques exprimé dans un système
de coordonnées
on va pouvoir passer à la résolution du
problème la dilatation du temps que l'on
veut calculer correspond au rapport
entre le rythme du temps de notre
horloge t et le temps propre de
l'astronaute il s'agit simplement de sa
vitesse temporel
c'est le rythme auquel augmente la corde
honnête et au cours du temps propre pour
calculer cette vitesse temporel on va
utiliser la norme du vecteur vitesse
dans l'espace temps tous les objets se
déplacent à la vitesse de la lumière
notre astronautes se déplace à la fois
dans le temps et dans l'espace
mais sa vitesse globale dans l'espace
temps est toujours égale à c'est la
norme d'un vecteur en relativité
générale se développe à partir du
tenseur métriques
c'est l'équivalent du théorème de
pythagore en développant la somme et en
y injectant les termes de la métrique de
schwarzschild on obtient une équation
qui relie directement les deux
composantes de la vitesse d'une part la
vitesse angulaire de l'astronaute c'est
à dire le rythme auquel augmente l'angle
qu'ils forment autour de la terre
et d'autre part sa vitesse temporel qui
est la valeur de dilatation qui nous
intéresse en réarrangeant les termes et
en utilisant le fait que la vitesse
d'orbites de la station est égal à sa
vitesse angulaire x son altitude on
obtient finalement l'expression de la
dilatation du temps que subit
l'astronaute par rapport à un
observateur lointain pour la station
spatiale internationale
on calcule une dilatation d'une
nanoseconde pour chaque seconde de temps
propre le temps de l'astronaute s'écoule
légèrement moins vite que celui de
l'observateur
exemple 2 une chute verticale dans ce
deuxième exemple ont souhaité décrire la
chute d'un satellite vers le soleil on
considère une chute verticale et on fait
la proxima sion que le soleil est une
sphère statique et peut donc être
décrits par la métrique de schwarzschild
on utilisera les mêmes coordonnées que
dans le cas précédent on se place à une
très grande distance et on mesure le
temps tu es sur notre horloge l'altitude
apparente
r entre le satellite et le centre du
soleil et les deux angles et à efi comme
la chute se fait verticalement les
ongles l'état et fille ne varie pas et
on peut d'ores et déjà s'en affranchir
la position du satellite ne dépend que
de son altitude et du temps dans cet
exemple on ne va pas s'intéresser à la
vitesse du satellite mais à son
évolution
on cherche l'accélération de ses
coordonnées pour ce faire on commence
par calcul et les symboles de christophe
elle dans la métrique de schwarzschild
avec nos coordonnées les symboles de
christophe elles prennent la forme
suivante une fois calculer on va pouvoir
les injecter dans l'équation des
géodésique l'équation des géodésique se
sépare en deux versions elle va nous
donner l'accélération du satellite sur
chacune de ces deux coordonnées d'une
part son accélération temporel et
d'autre part l'accélération de son
altitude
ces deux formules nous permettent
d'intégrer la trajectoire du satellite
au cours du temps propres connaissances
à vitesse à un instant donné
on peut calculer son accélération et
ainsi la façon dont changera cette
vitesse à l'instant suivant
pour aller plus loin il est possible
d'interpréter ces équations de façon
plus élégante
la première équation notamment peut être
mise sous une forme différente qui nous
indique la conservation d'une certaine
grandeur tout au long de la trajectoire
cette grandeur est directement liée à ce
qu'on appelle l'énergie dans la métrique
de schwarzschild l'énergie du satellite
dépendent de son altitude et de la
dilatation du temps
exemple 3 un rayon lumineux pour finir
en conclusion de cette série de vidéos
nous allons décrire ensemble la
trajectoire d'un rayon lumineux autour
d'un trou noir dans le cas d'un trou
noir statique l'espace temps est encore
une fois décrit par la métrique de
schwarzschild en relativité générale
la lumière est un cas bien particulier
que l'on va devoir traiter différemment
pour comprendre
reprenons quelques notions on a vu dans
les vidéos précédentes qu'un objet trace
une ligne d'univers dans l'espace temps
cette ligne d'univers peut être graduée
avec des intervalles de longues heures
fixes cette graduation sur la courbe
nous permet d'interpréter la ligne
d'univers comme un déplacement c'est ce
qu'on appelle le temps propre au cours
de son temps propre
l'objet se déplace dans l'espace temps
et on peut définir un vecteur de vitesse
spatio temporel mais contrairement à la
matière la lumière ne parcourt aucune
distance dans l'espace-temps deux points
sur sa ligne du ni verts sont toujours
éloignées d'une distance de zéro on ne
peut donc pas construire de temps propre
pour la lumière car elle ne parcourt
aucune distance en particulier
on ne peut pas définir le vecteur
vitesse d'un rayon lumineux car la
distance parcourue et le temps propre
écoulée sont toujours nul pour résoudre
ce problème
on va donc définir une nouvelle
graduation spécialement pour ce rayon
lumineux
cette nouvelle graduation est ce qu'on
appelle un paramètre affine
contrairement au temps propre le
paramètre affine n'a pas de vrai sens
physique il ne mesure aucune distance
dans l'espace temps il s'agit simplement
d'une graduation arbitraire qui va
servir d'intermédiaire mathématiques
pour les équations
grâce à ce paramètre affine on peut
définir une sorte de vecteurs vitesse et
ainsi utiliser l'équation des géodésique
qui reste vrai d'autre part on va
pouvoir également utiliser la norme de
ce vecteur
mais à la différence d'un objet de
matières ce pseudo vecteur vitesse que
l'on a artificiellement créée pour le
rayon lumineux à une longueur nul car la
lumière ne parcourt aucune distance sa
norme vaut donc zéro à cette petite
différence près on peut toujours
appliquer le même raisonnement que pour
les problèmes précédents et obtenir les
équations des géodésique qui régissent
le trajet des rayons lumineux au cours
de leurs paramètres affine autour d'un
trou noir
ces équations nous indique que la
lumière est déviée autour du trou noir
qui agit comme une lentille
gravitationnelle
[Musique]
on